pour l'entente sportive de wasquehal la
coupe de france reste une aventure parti
hier midi de la gare lille flandres le
voyage pour bordeaux allait rapidement
prendre des allures de périple les
voisins lillois ou lensois en ont
l'habitude bordeaux ce n'est jamais
qu'une heure d'avion mais pour moi ce
call la route du stade chaban delmas à
passer par le métro parisien
en obligé de se plier j'irai aux
difficultés un petit peu du club pour
dire pour boucler le budget pour prévoir
des déplacements
dans qui vont rentrer justement dans
leur budget alors il faut prendre le
métro pour la banlieue bah ouais ça peut
faire sourire mais bon nous on assure
yves bons parlant le début maintenant
maintenant obligé on sait en s'y habitue
pas banal c'est sûr mais pour survivre
financièrement le plus petit budget de
ligue 2 doit en passer par ce genre de
sacrifices évidemment ces conditions
sont loin d'être idéales pour préparer
un huitième de finale de coupe de france
mais ce voyage rocambolesque à souder un
peu plus fort les liens entre joueurs
surtout il classerait au rang de
grandissime exploit une qualification ce
soir en terre girondine
entre 1 et 2 heures de bus sony
voyager et
finalement reflète assez bien le monde
qui peut exister entre wasquehal et
bordeaux donc on essaiera demain de
montrer que le monde n'est pas si grand
que ça
et bordeaux justement les wasquehaliens
et sont enfin ce matin au petit déjeuner
l'équipe des girondins était dans tous
les esprits une dernière lecture pour
apprendre que save you et bien suspendu
ou que le portugais pauleta est toujours
incertain et le compte à rebours était
lancé
ça fait partie
des plaisirs qu'on a dans ce métier
c'est à dire le jouer comme des ailes
surtout contre une équipe comme bordeaux
donc oui c'est vrai plaisir
c'est quelque chose d'à part à partir de
20h longtemps a en tout cas rendez vous
avec son histoire le club de la
métropole lilloise n'a en effet jamais
réussi à passer le cap des huitièmes de
finale de coupe de france il y à un mois
et demi les hommes d'hervé gautier
faisait parler d'eux en sortant le grand
monaco de la compétition mais ce soir
wasquehal se verrait bien rajouter un
autre ténor de l'élite à son tableau de
chasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]